بدأت المرحلة التالية والأكثر
خطورة وصعوبة في عملية
طرد داعش من الموصل في الساعة 7 صباحًا
بتوقيت بغداد ، أعلن رئيس الوزراء العراقي
حيدر العبادي بدء هذه
العملية داعيًا القوات العراقية إلى
شن القتال ضد داعش في غرب
الموصل.  لكنها ستكون معركة صعبة
مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن هناك ما
بين 650 و 800 ألف
مدني في الجزء الغربي من
المدينة يعيشون بالفعل في ظل
ظروف صعبة حيث
تم عزل المدينة بسبب نقص
الغذاء والمياه الصالحة للشرب  الطب
الطهي وزيت التدفئة ، وبالتالي مع
تقدم القوات العراقية ،
سيتعين عليهم بذل قصارى جهدهم لتجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين الآن نفهم
من الجيش العراقي أن
تركيز هذا الهجوم في الوقت الحالي ينصب على
أربعة محاور من الجنوب في
سيحاولون جنوب غرب المدينة
استعادة مطار الموصل مع استمرار هذه
العملية لكنهم
سيواجهون التهديدات المعتادة.  في
مكان ما بين ألفين وثلاثة آلاف
مقاتل من داعش لا يزالون متبقين في المدينة ،
ما رأيناه في الجزء الشرقي
من المدينة والذي استغرقت القوات العراقية
حوالي ثلاثة أشهر ونصف لاستعادته
هو أن داعش تستخدم الكثير من القناصة الانتحاريين بالسيارات
المفخخة  والأفخاخ المتفجرة لذلك
يمكن أن تكون معركة طويلة وصعبة
ودموية